as an alternative to flu shots the flu
patch concept is equipped with 50 micro
needles around the size of a hair
follicle that penetrate the skin to
deliver the vaccine and researchers at
Plymouth University found that people
trying to quit eating certain foods or
smoking cigarettes can help stave off
cravings by simply playing 3 minutes of
tetris Vsauce Kevin here this is mine
scientists have studied the direct link
between our brain and the motion sensing
cells in our eyes although we've known
for a half-century of these cells that
help us know when something is moving
they've now studied the direction
sensing cells linked to the cortex which
can help us understand things like
dyslexia a new app is designed to
predict your future predictable z' is a
contemporary fortune-teller that uses an
algorithm to search for patterns in your
life to help predict what you should do
next by searching your calendar Facebook
friends and your interaction with the
digital world it could for instance
alert you if your significant other is
having a bad day and suggest that you
get them flowers the pre OVR is a
wireless virtual reality gaming suit
it's made up of body sensors to give you
the ultimate 360 degree low latency
real-time motion tracking experience
there are three versions an 8 sensor
upper-body unit for sitting on the couch
a 12 sensor unit for full-body tracking
and a 17 sensor unit that adds extra
control to the shoulders feet and hips
researchers at UC Berkeley are working
on a renewable energy source that
harnesses the power of waves the sea
floor carpet consists of a thin sheet of
rubber sitting atop hydraulic cylinders
that pump as it moves up and down with
the motion of the waves the hydraulic
pressure is then pumped to the shore and
converted into power ge is on the cusp
of a refrigerator revolution by using
magnets the process of using magnetic
material for refrigeration is projected
to be 20% more efficient than
traditional methods and it uses a
water-based fluid flowing through a
series of magnets to create heat rather
than a chemical refrigerant and
compressor
cycling these fridges would be much
easier on the environment and they hope
to have it available within the next
decade this drone is able to fly for
five years without refueling because it
runs on the power of the Sun the
Marquand is a 3d printer that is able to
print the lightest strongest material in
the world it's able to print continuous
carbon fiber which is stronger than
metal this breakthrough has applications
ranging from prosthetics and robotics to
making motorcycle parts and it ships in
the second half of 2014
emo spark claims to be the first
artificially intelligent emotion device
it's an Android powered Wi-Fi Cube that
lets users interact through conversation
music and visual media over time the
cube creates an emotional profile graph
essentially allowing it to feel and
express those emotions according to the
user and seek joy and satisfaction from
its owner
I feel happy computer simulations have
shown that using offshore wind turbines
can drastically reduce the power of
hurricanes by encountering an enormous
wind farm stretching many miles offshore
and along the coast professor Mark Z
Jacobsen found that hurricane wind
speeds could be reduced by up to 92
miles per hour and a storm surge
decreased by up to 79 percent and he
says that 78,000 wind turbines off the
coast of New Orleans would have
drastically changed the outcome of
Hurricane Katrina the world's oldest
chesse dates back to 16 15 BC and was
recently discovered as clumps on the
neck and chest of Chinese Mommy's so
yeah the Florida International
University discovery lab is developing a
real Robocop sort of the tell a bot
prototype is designed to help disabled
police officers the 6 foot tall 75 pound
robot can be controlled remotely by
officers and the head has live video
streaming in order to share visual
information the next step is developing
the outer shell and doing field testing
finally here's a responsive hexie wall
made up of 60 moving modules created by
Thibault
[Music]
I'm gonna leave it with by manual
manipulation for autonomous service
robots and as always thanks for watching
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]